اهلا بكم الصراع على التفوق التكنولوجي
والسيطره على القوى الروبوتيه والنزاع من
اجل التاثير على العقول معركه ضاريه بين
القوتين العظميين في العالم معركه تقودنا
الى عصر التوترات الاكثر خطوره الحرب
البارده اثنان نقطه صفر بين الولايات
المتحده والصين معركه ايديولوجيه حتى
الموت مسرحها الفضاء الالكتروني ومدارها
الانتصار التكنولوجي استضيف للحديث عن ذلك
كبير خبراء مركز جوشتاون للامن وتكنولوجيا
الناشئه ويليام هانز الذي كان يشغل منصب
الخبير التنفيذي للمشاريع التقنيه
المتقدمه في وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه من العربيه احييكم اينما كنتم
انا متهرمه وهذا البعد الاخر
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد من مرتفعاتي لاداغ شمال
الهند الى مضيق مياكو في جنوب اليابان
توترات عسكريه بين كتله غربيه تقودها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وجمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه كان هذا الصدام بين
الولايات المتحده والصين وتايوان في قلبها
ابرز محاور روايه الاستشراف بابل الدقيقه
0 في اسرائيل قرات الروايه من قبل الجميع
ولا سيما من قبل كل رؤساء الدول
والحكومات او رؤساء الدوله والحكومات
وتتناول الدور الجديد لتقنيات المعلومات
في الصراع بين الدول
فتيقظوا امريكا للصين ليس حديثا
ظهر للعلن خريف عام 2011 بعد ان تم التنبه
له اعتبارا من نهايه التسعينيات من قبل
بعض الاعضاء الذين سيكونون لاحقا مؤثرين
في اداره جورج بوش الابن بل وتاسس عليها
مشروع القرن الامريكي الجديد اليوم الصين
هي بالفعل قوه تكنولوجيه عظمى فلديها اكبر
قاعده للمستخدميه الانترنت في العالم مع
اكثر من مليار مستخدم عام 20 21 اي ثلاثه
اضعاف مثيلتها في الولايات المتحده
40% من سكانها يمارسون التجاره
الالكترونيه وعبر عروض فيديو حيه تتفوق
على نظارتها الامريكيه في معدات الاتصالات
السلكيه واللاسلكيه بثلاثه اضعاف ونصف اما
طائرات التجاريه بدون طيار فعشرون ضعف حجم
المبيعات الامريكيه
في عام 2020 كان لديها نفس كميات
الروبوتات الصناعيه التي تملكها الولايات
المتحده واليابان والمانيا وكوريا
الجنوبيه مجتمعه وهذا العام تجاوزت ايضا
الولايات المتحده في عدد المقالات البحثيه
المنشوره والاستشهاد بها في مجال الذكاء
الاصطناعي
المحلل الرئيسي في مركز جورج تاون للامن
والتكنولوجيا الناشئه ويليام هانس هو ضيفي
لهذه الحلقه ارحب به معكم اهلا بك معنا
سيد هاز
معكم
وفقا لمقالات الخبراء فان 80% مما يحتاجه
رئيس الولايات المتحده او رئيس اركان
الجيش الامريكي لاتخاذ قرار جاد ياتي من
مصادر مفتوحه كيف هذا
من
المصادر الاستخباراتيه الامريكيه والصينيه
فهي موثوقه وحتى قبل الانترنت او التواصل
الاجتماعي وانفجار المعلومات بشكل عام
ونفس الارقام ذكرت حينها واذا ما فكرنا
بالامر فنسال منطقيه فمن اكثر من له دافع
لعثر المعلومات الموظف الحكومي الذي يتلقى
مرتبه مهما عمله شهريا او المراسله الصحفي
الذي تعتمد حياته على العثور على
المعلومات والانباء الموثوقه كيف يمكن ان
يثق صانعوه القرار في استخبارات
المصادر ان يثقوا بالمصادر المفتوحه حتى
في شيء اشد الظروف قسوه
ولكن يطرح نفس السؤال على المعلومات
السريه المعلومات السريه او الاستخبارات
هي نفس الكلمه بالصينيه الذي هم كلمه
واحده او هي محفوفه بالكثير من المشاكل من
ضمنها ضعف السياق
المعلومات المظلله والابلاغ الدائري وحتى
الخداع شهدت حالات حيث بعض العملاء يبيعون
معلومات يدعون انها سريه ولكنهم في
الحقيقه حصلوا عليها مكتوبه في مقالات
الصحفيه كتبت باللغه لا يستطيع الضابط
قراءتها او يفهمها
لا المعلومات السريه ولا المسار مفتوح
يمكن تثق بها يجب ان نتحقق منها او نحللها
ونضعها في السياقه المناسب لكي تكون
موثوقه وحتى حينها بالنسبه الموثوقيه يجب
ان نتاكد منها وهنا ياتي دور الضباط
الاستخبارات
وهنالك
المفتوحه والسريه كلها ما يدعمه الاخر
والمصادر المفتوحه تؤكد المعلومات السريه
حسب الجهات الاستخباراتيه ولكن العلاقه في
الحقيقه هي بالعكس فهنالك تقارير قائمه
بالكامل على معلومات مفتوحه وتضاف اليها
المعلومات السريه فقط او مجرد للاضافه لكي
تؤخذ بجديه طيب يعني ركزلي مره اخرى واؤكد
لي على نوعيه هذه المصادر المفتوحه حسب
تجربتك واي هذه المصادر يمكن ان نقول بانه
اكثر اهميه من حيث توفير كميه المعلومات
ومن حيث دقتها
استخدام كلمه المصادر المفتوحه
والمصطلح الدرجه الان هو المعلومات
المتاحه للعامه ولكن هذا المصطلح يعطينا
مفهوما عن طبيعتها استطيع ان تكون لك
قائمه طويله من المصادر او لكن الابسط انا
فكر في الامر على هم المسار المفتوحه
المعلومات العامه المتاحه
قانونيا ومجانا او فقط مجانا وحسب مجالي
والذي
هو من اختصاصي وهو العلوم
التكنولوجيا نسبه 85% قد تصل الى مئه
بالمئه اي العملات استخباراتيه جمع
المعلومات العلميه والتكنولوجيه والعلماء
حول العالم يسرهم التحدث عن اعمالي مو
انجازاتهم ومن هنا نجمع هذه المعلومات
وحتى الوكالات المموله ايضا
تعلن المنح ولمن تمنحها وهذه ايضا مصدرا
جيد للمعلومات استخباراتيه لجمع المعلومات
العلميه والتكنولوجيا لا اريد ان اعطني
طباعه بين المسار المفتوحه سهله هي في
الحقيقه صعبه لان المصادر تجف اذا لم
تستخدم بحذر كما ان الكميه في حد ذاتها
تجعلها مخيفه
وعاده المصادر تكون بلغاتنا اجنبيه
وعلى نتعامل مع صادر المفتوحه بنفس
المهارات والسلوكيات التي يستخدمها
الجامعون والمحللون للمعلومات السريه وفي
الختام هيا نفس المهنه ونفس المنهجيات طيب
في احد كتبك حددت الصين باعتبارها الدوله
الاكثر تاثيرا في هذا المجال لو تشرح لي
اكثر عن هذا الموضوع
مره اخرى
انا اتحدث عن علومي ولا التكنولوجيا
لا اريد ان اخوض في المجالات الاخرى مصادر
الاخرى فقط العلوم والتكنولوجيا ولكن فقط
في هذا المجال فان النقاش حول ما تقوم به
الصين قد يملا مجلدات كامله وفي الحقيقه
بالفعل ملات مجلدات كامله فهي
تدير مراكز خاصه بالعلوم والتكنولوجيا
والمعلومات الاستخباراتيه وسمى والعملات
استخبارات جمع المعلومات العلميه
والتكنولوجيا منذ خمسينات القرن الماضي
وعدد اكبر يعملون في هذا المجال وهذه
العمليات اكثر من القوى العامله لكافه
الوكاله الاستخباريه في العالم مجتمعه الى
هذه الدرجه تاخذ الصين هذه المساله بجديه
ولكن الفارق الاساسي بين عمليات الصين
الاستيائي او مثلا الولايات المتحده الى
جانب الارقام غير متكافئه هي ان الولايات
تقوم بهذه العمليات لمراقبه التهدئه
التكنولوجيه نحن نحصل على المعلومات ولا
نمررها الى الشركات
وهذا الجدل سبق وان حصل وهذا ليس بالشيء
الذي نقوم به ولا نرغب ان نقوم به اما
الصين
فتدير برامج عن قبل الدوله لتعاقب
تكنولوجيا الاجنبيه والعلامه استخبارات هي
جزء اساسي من برنامج التي تديرها
لكن هل كل الاساليب الصينيه
يمكننا ان نقول انها مثيره للجدل او غير
قانونيه مثل قرصنه وسرقه وغيرها
هذا هو مجرد دار تمت الجبل الجليدين فان
عمليات الخاصنه والسرقه وكل اشياء غير
القانونيه هي جزء من
عده الصيني للحيازه حيازه التكنولوجيا
العالميه ولكنها ليست الاداه الاهم
مجال تتميز فيه الصين هي الحيازات في
المنطقه الرماديه وهي الحوالات الماليه
غير الخاضعه للرقابه
وقانونيته غير معروفه
تعرفنا على اكثر من 12 فئه من هذا القبيل
مثلا العمليات او الحوالات غير الاخلاقيه
سواء عن طريق الرشاوه او البرامج الدوليه
سيئه السمعه والمشاريع التعاونيه احاديه
الجانب وكذلك استغلال الصين المهجرين او
جاريه المهجره
كتبا بهذه المعلومات كتاب مثل هذا
تولى في دول اخرى ايضا تستهدفها الصين
تستهدف كافه الدول المتقدمه من اجل
التكنولوجيات وحالات تخسر الصين امكانيه
الوصول الى التكنولوجيا في دوله مثلا
الولايات المتحده وبعد ذلك تبدا
بالتعويض في دول اخرى ولكن يجب ان نكون
منصفين فان نقل التكنولوجيا سؤال القانون
او غير الاخلاقي هذه ممارسه عالميه والكل
يقوم بذلك اما الصين فهي تفعل ذلك اكثر من
غيرها وافضل من غيرها ايضا بس كيف بتم
تحويل التكنولوجيا المستورده اذا كانت
مستورده او مسروقه حتى الى منتجات في
الصين هذا هو السؤال
هذا سؤال وجيه
المحل المستقبال ياتيون
بحثوا فيه كثيرا ويبدو ان الصين لديها
شبكه
فيها حوالي 900
منتجعات التكنولوجيه مدعومه من قبل الدوله
لديهم اسماء مختلفه لهذه المجمعات
والارقام ربما اكثر من 900 الان ولكنها
موجوده فقط
لاستغلال هذه التكنولوجيا على الصعيد
التجاري او حتى لتحويلها الى اسلحه
واستخدامك اسلحه وهذا مجمعات
احجام مختلفه تماما من مباني فيها عده
طوابق او حتى اماكنها فيها عدد صغير من
الاشخاص وهنا تاتي عمليه التحويل هذه
التكنولوجيا الى المجال التجاري
في الجانب العسكري ولا في الجانب التجاري
او الجانب الخدماتي
اعتمد على متطرحين السؤال عليه ولكن كلا
واحده فينا في هذا المخاطر المشكله الاكبر
الان هنالك نوعان من التكنولوجيا العسكريه
او المدنيه وما يسمى التكنولوجيا ثنائيه
الاستخدام وذات الاستخدام المزدوج والذكاء
الاصطناعي غير مثال على ذلك
ارجو ان تبقى معنا سنذهب الى فاصل قصير
نعود بعده لمتابعه حوارنا مع المحل
الرئيسي في مركز جورج تاون للامن
والتكنولوجيا الناشئه واليوم معنا
ومشاهدينا الكرام ارحب بكم معنا من جديد
في البعد الاخر وارحب معي بالمحلل الرئيسي
في مركز جورج تاون للامن والتكنولوجيا
الناشئه السيد
اهلا بك معنا من جديد اذا ناقشنا نتيجه
لابحاثك حول التطورات الصينيه في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي تحديدا لوين ممكن ان
نتجه
لا احد
الكره بلوريه او لا استطيع قراءه المستقبل
ولكن ما نعرفه الى الان هو ان كايفولي
الخبير الصيني في ذكاء الصناعي وذكر في
كتابه القوى الخارقه في الذكاء الاصطناعيه
قل بان الشركات الصينيه بها السمعه في
تحويل التكنولوجيا التجاريه من ضمنها حتى
ذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن الصيني لم تكن
الرائده في العالم في ابتكار تكنولوجة
جديده كل هذا صحيح ولا جدل في ذلك ولكن
هنالك ادله في كتابنا ساريكم اياه وهو
القوى الصينيه وذكاء الاصطناعي
وان هذا نموذج بدا يتغير
تشاهدته مشهورات علميه ومؤتمرات علميه
وابحاثه
لمختبراتك صناعي مملكه للدوله او خاصه
الصين تحقق وتقدمها كبيره في مجالات متقدم
ذكاء الاصطناعي لمعالجه المشاكل في هذا
المجال باستخدام الاساليب الابداعيه التي
لا
تتبع
الممارسات المعموله بها
خلصت لان الصين تنتهج استراتيجيه وطنيه
لقياده العالم في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحلول عام 20 30 وهذا كان يعني في في احد
في واحد من دراسات التي نشرت عنك ما هي
ميزات هذا المشروع الصيني
الصين لغايه 2015
لم تعترف بالذكاء الاصطناعي ولم تعده
كمجال له الاولويه
ولكن دائما ما كان له صله بشيء اخر هذا
التغير في عام 2017
حيث
اصدروا خطه وطنيه مكثفه لتطوير الذكاء
الاصطناعي وهذه الخطا طويله ولا حتى ارفع
الصفحاتها ولكنها تغطي كافه المجالات
المرتبطه بذكاء الاصطناعي وعبروا وبكل
وضوح في تلك الوثيقه ان هدفهم
للتغلب على العالم فكره الاصطناعي بحلول
عشرين ثلاثين
راجعنا الخطه وبشكل خاص اللي ما يحصل الان
في الصين وتقدمها في ذكاء الاصطناعي
وحددنا ثلاثه مقاربات
نرى اتخاذ الصيني لها
الصناعي احداها التقليديه وهي على
البيانات الكبرى
وهي الان تنافس بقيه العالم في درجه
تعقيدها وتقدمها كما يبحثون ايضا انكتب
فيما يسمى بالذكاء الاصطناعي تلهم من
الدماغ او مستوحى من الدماغ ومقاربه ذلك
مختلفه فيحاولوا ان يحاكي الاجراءات
البيولوجيه والطبيعيه لخلق ذكاء اصطناعي
اكثر وقدره مجال اخر تعرفنا عليه
واجهات الدماغ الحاسوبيه الروابط بين
الدماغ الانساني
والكمبيوترات تعمل في هذا بشكل كبير
وبشكل متزايد نرى ان هذا العمل ليس فقط
اعمال طبيعه واجهزه
اعضاء الصناعيه
يجب ان تشمل ذلك كجزء من برامجها الذكاء
الاصطناعي طيب اذا قارنت جهود الولايات
المتحده لمواجهه منافستها الصين في هذا
المجال كيف يبدو وضعها
الاجابه التقليديه هي ان الولايات المتحده
تقود في الرقاقات والتصنيع والصين متقدمه
في توافر البيانات البيانات وهذا المهمه
جدا لخوارزميه التعلم الاله وكلاء البلدان
الذين هم صناعات قويه وبعد تركيز مختلف
لكل دوله انا شخصيا اعتقد المتحده
وبريطانيا
يركزان اكثر من اللازم على حلول البيانات
الكبرى وفيها فوائد تجاري قصيره الامد الى
عدا الزملاء في المركز يخالفوني الراي
ولكن نرى ان جوانب هامه من مجموعه الخاصه
بالابحاث الذكاء الاصطناعي في الصين
الكبرى وتعلم الاله وهذا كان الصناعيه
التقليدي
لمستقبل لاحد
ويضعون الكثير من الموارد اقصده في الصين
في التكنولوجيا المستوحاه من الدماغ طيب
لماذا لم تعد الولايات المتحده هي القوه
المهيمنه في مجال البحث والتطوير في جميع
انحاء العالم كما كانت لماذا تعتبرها عرضه
للمفاجاه التقنيه
على الجامعات الامريكيه مؤخرا
العلوم الطبيعه والرياضيه فقدت او فقد
الاهتمام بها بشكل كبير نحن نشتكي من
الطالب الصينيين واقول انهم يسرقون
التكنولوجيا ولكن يحق لنا ان نقول بان
ادوارهم
محاصره ادوارهم ايجابيه في الجامعات
الامريكيه الاخرى هي الغرور الامريكي
هذه المشكله تواجه الامم التي اعتلت القمه
لفتره طويله جدا مثال شخصي مثلا تقدمت
لمنحه منذ فتره لدراسه
البرمجيات لمعالجه اللغات الطبيعيه ورفضت
المنحه لان الوكاله الحكومه الامريكيه
ادعت انها تعرف كل ما هنالك وكل ما هو
ضروري حول التكنولوجيا المفتوحه وهذه هي
العقليه التي تؤثر علينا بشكل سلبي هنا
ما الذي يعيق قدره الولايات المتحده على
مراقبه الذكاء الاصطناعي والتطورات الاخرى
عاليه التقنيه في الصين او في اي مكان اخر
في العالم
نفس الغرور الذي وصفته قبل قليل نحن نعتقد
ان المتقدمون جدا وليس من الضروري ان نبذل
الجهد او ان استثمر والسبب الاخر
وانا لا اتحدث عن الولايات المتحده بل
استخبارات الغربيه بشكل عام كلها منحازه
تجاه المعلومات السريه
ويجمع المعلومات مصادر المفتوحه ويحللونها
ولكن هي اقل نسبيا ولا اخذها على نفس
الجديه كما ياخذون المعلومات السريه
وبالتالي او نتيجه لذلك فهناك ميزانيات
اقل واراده اضعف
لوضع البرمجه الخاص بمراقبه المصادر
المفتوحه حاليا تكنولوجيا الاجنبيه هذا
شيء لم يفعلوه من قبل لكن كيف يمكن
الموازنه بين نقل التكنولوجيا المتعلقه
بالامن القومي والتبادل الحر وقوانين
التجاره الدوليه
جدا ومن الصعب الاجابه عنه قبل عامين في
عام 2021
نقطه من الاشعه يمكن نقوم بها
للتحقيق الدوليه من دون استئنافي استنزافي
التكنولوجيا الخاصه هنا في الولايات
المتحده هذه القائمه حد ذاتها كانت منقحه
من قائمه ب 30 نقطه وكانت سريه صدرت قبل
ثلاثه
اعوام او ثلاثه اعوام قبل عشرين واحد نفس
الاهداف
الافكار موجوده
ولكن لا توجد اي اراده او رغبه بتطبيقها
ليس الى الان على الاقل اعتقد بان العنصر
الاهم بين كل نقاط التي تحدثنا عنها هي ان
الولايات المتحده والدول الاخرى
يجب ان توضح ما هي القواعد الدوليه وما هو
مقبول وما هو غير مقبول اقصد من السلوكيات
وليس على الجميع ان يخمنه في هذه المرحله
يجب ان اكون واضحين تماما ويجب ان نضمن ان
كل ما يدخل بلادنا الابحاث والقيام باعمال
مع الخصوم الاستراتيجيين كما يسمون هنالك
قواعد واضحه ومعروفه ونفعل ذلك
لتطبيق القوانين بشكل متساوي بين الجميع
ومن دون انحياز ما الذي يمكن ان
تنصح لمعالجه نق
اط الذات المتحده
والحكومات الاخرى اشرت اكثر من مره
لحكومات اخرى قلت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والاخرين
مجموعه الضغط عبر البحار مجموعه مؤثره جدا
تحاول انقل الخساره التكنولوجيه من ونحن
او هي تقول بان الغير بنسميه هم عنصريه
تجاههم ولكن في الحقيقه اكبر جنوبيه
واليابان واكلها دول اسيويه هي من اكبر
المنتقدين
النشاطات الصينيه غير الاخلاقيه والذين
فصل كامل بهذا الخصوص حول شكاوى الجنوبيه
واليابان
النشاطات الطابور الخامس هذه يجب ان تعالج
ولكن يجب ان تعالج من دون التضحيه بالقيمه
الليبراليه هذه مساله هامه هنالك حركه
نشطه في الدوار الاكاديميه في الولايات
المتحده واوروبا ايضا ونسميها
بمبادره الامن الابحاث والتي تعمل على هذا
المجال المساله الثانيه الولايات المتحده
وحكومات الحديثه هي توسيع علوم او مراقبه
علوم المطار المفتوحه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
من اجل تجنب المفاجات غير الساره نحن نعرف
كيف نفعل ذلك قمنا باداره بعض البرامج
الاولويه او التجريبيه نعرف كيف نبحث عنها
وكيف نقيم البيانات وما هو طبيعي وما هو
غير طبيعي وانا ارى بعض البدايات الواعده
هنا وهناك في امريكا وفي بريطانيا ولكننا
لازلنا بعيدون جدا عن المستوى الذي يجب ان
نصل اليه
وفيما يخص معالجه نقاط الضعف
اعتقد ان التوصيه الاخيره هي واضحه جدا
وهي ان الولايات المتحده عليها ان تعيد
الاستثماري في البنى التحتيه التكنولوجيه
والعلميه وان تبدا برعايه الموهبه العلميه
بحق المحاوله التمسك
بجزء الصغير من هذه الكعكه لن يصلنا الى
مكان مرغوب فيه
المحلل الرئيسي في مركز جورج تاون للامن
والتكنولوجيا الناشئه واليماها ناسا شكرا
جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا الف شكر
والى هنا مشاهدي الكرام انتهت حلقه اليوم
من البعد الاخرين يمكنكم دائما متابعتنا
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك
ويوتيوب كما يمكنكم الاستماع الى حلقتنا
على العربيه بودكاست ومتابعتها على منصه
شاهد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]